قاعدتنا الجويتان في العراق
اللتان تعرضت فيهما القوات الأمريكية للهجوم ،
أعلنت إيران مسؤوليتها مباشرة الآن
وفقًا للبنتاغون ، حيث
تم إطلاق أكثر من اثني عشر صاروخًا باليستيًا
على قاعدة الأسد وقواعد القانون العربي في حوالي
الساعة 5:30 مساءً.  في التوقيت الشرقي الذي تشاهد فيه
مقطع فيديو تم إصداره لتلك
الصواريخ عند الإطلاق ، تشير
التقارير المبكرة إلى أن هذه الصواريخ
ربما تم إطلاقها محليًا من قبل
وكلاء إيرانيين ، الأمر الذي كان من الممكن أن يكون
خطوة أقل تطرفاً ، لا ، ليس هذا هو
الحال مع مسؤولي وزارة الدفاع.  يقولون إنه
من الواضح أنهم انطلقوا من إيران
ردًا على الغارة الجوية التي قتلت
قائدًا إيرانيًا كبيرًا بشكل عام الأسبوع الماضي ، وهذا
يعني على الأقل أن تلك الصواريخ قد
سارت على بعد 800 ميل من هنا في
أربيل إلى أقرب حدود إيران إذا كان
هذا هو المكان الذي أتوا منه.  وفي
القاعدة الثانية ، كانت المسافة أكبر قليلاً بنحو 900
ميلاً الآن
مما كان سيحدث إذا
أطلقت عليها محليًا ، لكنها كانت
صواريخ أكثر تطورًا مما يعني أن
لديها أنظمة استهداف أفضل مما
يعني أنها يمكن أن تكون أكثر دقة
وأن  يقودنا إلى سؤال مثير للاهتمام
في لحظة ولكن إليك المزيد من المعلومات
حول ما نعرفه عن سقوط صاروخين في
أربيل أحدهما في المطار  هـ
المطار الدولي هناك يفيد
التقرير أنه لم ينفجر
آخر وسقط خارج المدينة ولم
يبلغ عن إصابات